[Musique]
tous les quatre ans
darques c'est une association qui
transmet l'art de la danse et de la
musique dans le département de l'indre
elle organise également depuis plus de
40 ans le stage festival darc à
châteauroux qui fait de cette ville une
capitale de la danse derrière tout ça
éric belley et son équipe de 150
bénévoles oeuvrent pour amener cette
culture au coeur des quartiers en zone
rurale comme zones urbaines alors c'est
parti pour danser les fêtards
presse parce que je vis le truc à fond
les filles font vivre un truc non
je sais qu'il ya sagna et ses noix mais
alors qui est qui donc c'est à dire
celles présentes elles dansent samira je
maîtrise donc effectivement vous êtes
soeur
qui rêve d'en faire son métier et on a
une qui fait ça pour le loisir donc moi
j'aimerais plus tard en faire mon métier
je pratique la danse classique la danse
modern'jazz donc exactement les pales
j'aurai à chaque fois tu sors une danse
je te sors la danse hip hop ça je savais
que lui
voilà maintenant un mot du monde comme
éric belley qu'est ce que ça représente
pour vous c'est notre papa de la danse
il est toujours là nous aider à nous
motiver
c'est notre papa quoi je regarde il est
là bas voilà coûté merci des filles je
vais aller à sa rencontre en dansant
comme ça je vais vous faire honneur
[Musique]
vous
pour moi non
enchantée eric alors j'ai tout donné on
m'a dit j'ai vu j'ai shooté fame pour
venir jusqu'à toi est ce que ça te
rappelle quelques souvenirs quand tu
visites le stage international de danse
c'est ça que je veux faire passer
cfm à la française à château aujourd'hui
on est à plus de la 40e édition de ce
festival a pour moi un peu les les
prémices première édition 76 et une
cinquantaine de stagiaires viennent et
puis tranquillement on a installé trois
quatre disciplines modern jazz
contemporain danse classique claquette
je suis époustouflée tu sais tout faire
le stage la danse la musique c'est du
partage et toi un de tes objectifs c'est
vraiment amener cette culture au coeur
des quartiers que ce soit en zone
urbaine mon zones rurales à c'est
vraiment ce que l'on aime faire les
stagiaires le dernier jour après le
spectacle final lorsqu'ils repartent
vers leur ville à la gare de châteauroux
c'est des mômes des quartiers qui font
le revoir en musique percussions et en
danse en tout cas cette année si vous
manque à danseurs vous pouvez compter
sur moi bienvenue à châteauroux merci
eric
moonwalk
voir que mon boulot incroyable
mais d'abord approché on aidera les
qu'eric et les mots clés pour que je
participe au festival à vos côtés donc
c'est officiel le grand maître a parlé
jacques daigre votre ex aequo en
alliant théâtre et
d'art on n'est pas content oui
tu dois vraiment vous prenez qui passe
oui oui oui mais là pas le niveau
débutant même pas une initiation il
après les bases soient pas garder la
forme